>> Hello everyone.
I'm Ashish Kapoor,
and I welcome you on behalf of
the AirSim Team at
Microsoft Research.
So, the recent successes in
machine learning and
reinforcement learning
have been very impressive,
but they've been
limited to scenarios,
such as Arcade Games and
Game of Go, et cetera.
Typically, closed
world situations,
where your AI agent
doesn't need to worry
about the exogenous factors,
such as when pedestrians
or the cars, et cetera.
Consequently, we,
at the AirSim team have been
thinking about how to take
these techniques and apply
them to real-world tasks,
such as autonomous driving,
flight, robotics, et cetera.
Consequently, the key idea
that we've been working on
is to create these
high-fidelity simulations,
which are essentially
video game on
steroids that are played by
autonomous system agents.
So, the whole idea being that and
AI pipeline if it
doesn't access to
a simulated environment in
which it can take actions,
and if the such a
simulator environment has
high-fidelity then we can
hope to train AI systems,
which then we can
deploy in real world.
So, what I'll do is,
I'll ask Shital Shah who's
the Lead Architect for
our AirSim pipeline to
give you a little bit more
details about AirSim.
>> Thank you Ashish. So, we
want to show you
some of the features
that we have built and what
you can do with AirSim.
So, AirSim is open-source
cross-platform project.
So, you can get it right now,
there are the releases,
where you can download binaries,
you can start playing
with right away.
It works on Windows,
as well as the Linux.
Here are some of the
things you can do with it.
So, AirSim provides you
all this ground truth,
with depth view
segmentation view,
which is very hard to
get in real world,
but you can obtain in
simulation very nicely.
So, you can do lot of computer
vision and learning task.
We have built drones simulation,
as well as car simulation.
So, here you can see
the city environment and
you can see this big city,
this is related to big city
that we have built.
This is another environment
from Hawaii Hana Highway,
where you can drive
the car and you can test
your self-driving algorithms,
and you can do lot
of detection and
object recognition
stuff, for example,
identifying animals,
identifying objects,
and you can also do a lot
of machine learning,
reinforcement learning
work in AirSim,
where you can build
your reward function
and try out ideal algorithms
in the open worlds.
So, this is a great resource
platform for reinforcement.
There are some examples stuff
we've been trying to do.
For example here, car is trying
to learn how to drive
without collisions.
So, with saying that,
let me move over to my colleague,
Jim, and he can show you
more about the environments.
>> Thanks Shital. As
Shital indicated,
I'm Jim Piavis and
I'm a member on
the AirSim team at MS Research.
So, AirSim actually
supports a number of
different environments and
since we build on Unreal 4,
it's a relatively common
skillset that we can actually go
out and find on the open market
actually build our environments.
The nice thing is that,
we can rapidly build these out
and it just depends
on the complexity.
As Shital indicated and he
showed a little bit earlier,
we have a number of different
environments that we use.
These were all constructed using
typical modeling tools
such as 3D Max,
Maya, whatever it takes basically
for 3D animation and creation.
What you're looking at now is,
a warehouse
environment we did for
Toyota materials handling for
the Hannover Messe show
several months ago.
It shows several different drones
that Toyota was working on and
how those might be visualized
within that warehouse
environment.
We can apply
reinforcement learning
to each of the hero actors within
the scene as they teach
themselves how to
actually maneuver
within the warehouse.
This was probably
constructed I think
it took a total of
about three and half weeks
and a couple of
people to actually build this and
it originated on a set of
CAD drawings provided to
us from the customer.
This is a little bit more complex
for those that have
been in Building 99.
This is the interior or
at least the lower floor
of Building 99,
which involves both the atrium,
the cafe, some of
the office areas,
and it's a relatively
complex environment.
This environment had to
be entirely hand created,
but what we used was a drone to
capture roughly 400 to
500 images of the atrium.
Then we reconstructed
a point cloud using
photogrammetry and used that
as very accurate
reference material.
Then after handing that
off to our art team,
they're able to
actually reconstruct
the entire scene over the course
of about three weeks.
I think we had
three to four folks
working on this at
any given time,
and it actually turned out to be
quite a nice little environment.
Shital also showed
the city environment
we've built an entire city,
which includes
vehicles, pedestrians,
which can be varied
place to place,
we have whether
particle effects that can
be configured within the scene,
and we've also been
able to support the latest
Microsoft Build Conference,
which was held about a month
and a half ago.
We had an interesting
activity for
the developers to construct
an AI application,
leveraging cognitive services
to identify objects.
In this case, what we have is
real-world objects
in the upper right.
The upper left is the synthetic
images, which we built.
Those were placed on
a soccer field and then we
basically flew a drone within
the AirSim application,
collecting visual data, which
was then sourced through
to cognitive services for
object identification.
In the end, we were actually able
to achieve about
an 85 percent hit rate
between the training we
sourced on synthetic objects
versus the real-world,
and we think this is very
promising in the future,
where we can use
synthetic environments to
train in for external.
Finally, we do have environments
we used for drones,
this was actually somewhat of
an out-of-the-box scenario
with mountains,
but what we did is
augmented with power lines,
so that we can start
teaching the drone through
reinforcement learning
how to actually stay
on the power lines as
you see in a scene.
So, we're using
a combination of say,
out of the box, which
are quickly sourced,
we can grab those and then if we
need to do any custom
modifications,
we can do that with the scene.
So, the scenes are
very extensible,
they're easy to create,
we can get things turned
around pretty quick.
So, hopefully, this is
a pretty good primer
on what we're doing with
AirSim. Thank you very much.